now there very few scientists or people
of any sort whose pictures hang in my
office but I have a picture of URI
hanging up looking at me to remind me
all the time of the scientific standards
that I try and maintain
today's quite decide day for me because
I've just received copy of a Russian
scientific journal which contains the
bitchery of one of my close friends and
collaborators professor uriga barton he
was an excellent scientist who has been
a great friend of me and my students
here in Nottingham but let me explain to
you what he did he was born in Chechnya
before the war the second world war and
then moved to Moscow he used to tell me
about how he had gone to Red Square in
Moscow the day that Stalin died in 1953
and then for the last 40 years he's
worked in an institute in a town called
China goloka quite near Moscow the
Institute of men our mineralogy
that's making minerals and because he
was interested in how minerals were
formed he was very interested in the
properties of high-temperature water
Yuri was the sort of scientist who it's
called the spectroscopy he studied the
absorption of light by substances and
particularly he studied the absorption
of infrared light by water and the idea
of his experiments was to try and
understand how the nature of water
changes when it's under very high
temperature and pressure such as you
find deep underground where minerals are
being formed and it's really hard to do
experiments at high temperature and
pressure and Urey with probably the
leading scientist in the world for
studying water under these conditions
let me explain to you the problem the
problem is that if you're studying the
absorption of infrared light by water it
absorbs the infrared light very strongly
so you need a very very thin layer much
thinner than one of my hairs so you need
to have two transparent windows very
very close together
and at very high temperature and very
high pressure and so this is one of the
cells that you rebuilt and he built this
and gave it to us in Nottingham so it
consists of a heated cell here and a
tube to put in the water under high
pressure the light goes in here and it
comes out through a hole at this end you
can see if I turn it you can see so I
can shine the light so you're seeing the
light going through the cell but what's
miraculous about the cell is that when
it's at high temperature of 500 degrees
and the pressure of 15 hundred
atmospheres that's extraordinarily harsh
conditions you can move one window
relative to the other and you can do
this by turning a screw here which moves
this arm backwards and forwards and
because the pressure is so high if you
used ordinary metal here it would just
Bend because you're pushing so hard with
the windows but Yuri used a special
Soviet alloyed that was made before the
fall of communism in 1991 it's no longer
made which is so strong that it can move
without bending this cell was used by
generations of students in my lab who
worked with Yuri and what he did was he
arrived in Nottingham and inspired my
students became their scientific
grandfather they used to write to him
when he'd got back to Russia telling him
about their lives
sending him photos of their children
when they got married and he was a
remarkable person because although he
was Russian he wrote the most beautiful
English his written English was much
better than those of most of my English
students but he had great difficulty in
speaking English and so I usually used
to speak speak to him
in Russian and my students somehow
managed to get along but he represents a
completely dying generation of
scientists who were passionate about
their science and were fantastically
good experimentalists they could do
experiments which nobody else could they
could design equipment which the younger
scientists can only dream about and so
he was a fantastic example to my
students and to scientists across the
world he had a terrific reputation I
visited his lab once in China goloka it
was a lovely lab very like a Russian lab
there was a table where you could sit
down and have tea which is not allowed
in the UK but is really good for
stimulating discussions and it was a
real privilege to have known him and
it's a sad loss to Russian science into
science across the world that he's died